las mascarillas se acercan a su fin en
españa a partir del 26 de junio dejarán
de ser obligatorias en exteriores
volveremos con ello pues a disfrutar de
una vida en la calle sin mascarilla
sobre todo ya mí me gustaría rendir en
primer lugar tributo a los españoles
españolas al conjunto de compatriotas
que han sido disciplinados todo este
tiempo con más de una cuarta parte de la
población española completamente
vacunada alemán ya retirado de su lista
de zonas de riesgo algunas partes de
españa junto a francia grecia y suiza
noruega también se está relajando a
partir del domingo la gente podrá
reunirse en grupos más grandes
habrá más visitantes extranjeros y los
bares y restaurantes permanecerán
abiertos después de la medianoche sin
embargo algunas partes de europa van en
sentido contrario en medio de un pico de
contagios los ciudadanos de lisboa y sus
alrededores no podrán salir de su zona
de los fines de semana una medida que no
todos se han tomado igual
no ha habido ninguna mejora casi dos
años con el kobe y esta es la situación
no puedo criticar las medidas porque son
realmente necesarias como es necesario
que la gente entienda que esto aún no ha
terminado es comprender seguir siéndolo
a cabo mientras tanto italia ha vuelto a
imponer una cuarentena de cinco días
para quienes lleguen desde reino unido
la propagación de la variante delta allí
ha una semana el levantamiento
definitivo de las restricciones
paralelamente la misma variante ha
generado un récord de contagios en moscú
por eso las zonas de aficionados a la
eurocopa permanecerán cerradas y se
mantendrá el cierre de los cafés y
restaurantes' a las 11 de la noche